- So wait, are,...
I heard that Ashton recently, he said,
he talked about the first
time he said, "I love you."
- [Mila] Oh.
- [Kelly] He said he was super drunk?
- [Mila] Yeah. - Is that real?
- Here's the irony in how real it is.
It happened to me, and
it happened to my mother.
So,...
(Kelly laughing)
my dad told my mom he was in
love with her three months
into their relationship,
shammered, fully shammered.
And my mom went, "All right,
talk to me in the morning."
Like, we'll reconvene this.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Same thing happened
to me with my husband.
Three months into our relationship,
he like showed up at my house
at two o'clock in the morning.
And he was like, "I love you so much."
And I was like, "Oh Lord, have mer...
I was like, "Go to bed."
And he goes, "No, and I love you so much."
And I was like, "Okay, if you remember...
- [Kelly] Super great, go home.
- [Mila] Yeah, like go to
night-night, night-night.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But same thing, and
then in the morning...
My dad and my husband both...
- [Kelly] I think what we've
learned here is not about them,
but you, and your mom
are very powerful women.
Like three months in, and
they're just like done.
I like that.
- Three months in, but,
but Ashton and I have
known each other for...
- [Kelly] Oh, that's true, that's true.
- [Mila] 20 years.
- [Kelly] Yeah. - [Mila] Yeah.
- [Kelly] A little show
called That 70's Show.
Yeah, yeah, that's true.
Totally forgot until just now.